what was your first awareness of Oscar
Wilde well I think as a child my mom
read me the Happy Prince and it
resonated with me a lot when I was about
six or seven I think partly because
one's relationship with one's mother is
the best relationship in the world at
that point and I remember her so well
with she was in her jackie onassis
period with white earrings and short
hair and a little mini dress and I was
just perfectly happy and we were very
conventional conservative families so we
didn't talk much about love or say I
love you and things like that so hearing
about love and suffering and the price
paid for love in the Happy Prince it's
quite a it's quite a gothic story for a
little child and it made a great
impression on me and that was why I
really very much wanted to try and weave
it through the film it did serve as the
bookends as well as the texture the
bookends knows have made it liaison
between Oscar Wilde's two children and
the surrogate family I I made for him in
in France and so as you learned more
about wild did it stick in the back of
your mind that this is someone whose
story needs to be told more better more
engagingly
I think when I was about seventeen and
came to London it was in 1975 and I
straightaway I come from a fairly
conventional monastic background and I
threw myself into the the gay scene and
without realising really that in fact it
had only been legal to be gay in the UK
for seven years and the law by which it
was legalized was very oblique and so
the police were kind of 20 years behind
the law which was about private displays
of homosexuality versus public ones so
we were always been raided by police and
herded into paddy wagons and spending
the nights in prison and so I think that
gay scene felt very much that it was
walking in the footsteps of Oscar Wilde
they all knew the name Oscar Wilde even
if they didn't know exactly what what
they knew it for and so that also was
made a big impression on me and then of
course later on in my career I started
doing wild in the theatre and that for
me was a very lucky thing I had a great
rapport with the text
and when an actor discovers a writer
that works very well for him and the
audience and him get along very well
it's a it's a magic thing and then one
thing led to another I did two films
that they did they went quite well - I
think Wilde adapts beautifully to the
cinema if you play it the right way
because it's it's like the witty
comedies from Hollywood in the 1940s
almost and and then in about 2007
putting all this in a nutshell my own
career kind of had dried ground to a
halt and I'd written a couple of books
and I thought I'd try and I'd always
thought I'd try and segue that writing
into script writing and I thought Oscar
Wilde would be the best character for me
to try and write a story about why did
it then take so long we hear about two
mill epics being four years in the
making this was ten years in the making
but I think it's because the main reason
is the independent cinemas is such a
strangled situation now you know very
few people are going to see it there's
in the Europe in England anyway there's
only three outlets for finance really
and then in Europe there's quite a lot
but it's very difficult it's not it's
not easy anyway and I suppose you know
it just I did it at the wrong time
nobody was that excited at the beginning
of the of the process and in what they
say in America getting into the Rupert
Everett business the writing of this
then how much having known what about
Wilde having read about him having
played him on stage how difficult was
then to write and direct as well as
perform while to get that almost a third
person point of view about something
you're so engrossed in yourself but of
course I think writing about a
historical character in a way it's much
easier than if you're creating a script
that is entirely your own thing because
you've got scenes out of history to look
at you can choose from million scenes
ones that you really like you also have
a lot of dialogue that you can pilfer
and rearrange for yourself so in one
sense you're given a lot of help writing
about someone right wild on the other
side obviously you have a very high
benchmark to try and create your own
Wild Ian text and I think but in one
sense of the whole process of making my
film it was the most
it was rather like it was wonderful I
really enjoyed it and I you know
becoming a wild sleuth was great fun
going to the hotels he lived in going to
Naples and discovering the flat he
stayed in and all that kind of stuff is
just heavenly for me what was the
physicality of the role like for you
even though you've done it on stage was
it any different from film well I think
being on the stage was very very useful
for me considering I was directing the
film and acting in it because there's
nothing like being in a play to really
really learn about a character and even
though the character the action was
different in in David hares played to my
film still the character was very much
the same and I learned an awful lot
about him because I performed in the
play for about two or three years on and
off and so when I got to the point where
I was in the movie and directing I could
really switch into the character without
having to have too much quiet time or
downtime
he wasn't perhaps the first we'd say
international celebrity but but he was
one of the early ones he certainly was
one of the first two or three people who
were famous for the sum total of him
famous for being famous here in the
States he really was famous for being
famous he traveled around America like
j.lo in his own train and he did go down
with the minor is wearing a purple
sweater with the miners in a purple suit
he had his whole train reupholstered in
green leather and and he lectured miners
down in the mines on beauty the need for
beauty and things like that I mean quite
extraordinary thing really he went to
San Fran so he went all over the place
so he really was famous for being famous
he was known and that's the other thing
that's I think very very interesting
about my story not the way I told it but
they eyed the picture of it is that in
Paris in 1888 1898 and 99 and 1900 asker
Wilde was the image of the first out gay
man in modern times homosexuality didn't
exist as a word women never ever ever
would have even known had a clue that
men might have had sex with each other
they hardly had a clue that men had sex
with them
and and there wasn't a word for it when
they saw wild on the street
and he was famous so everyone knew him
then they saw they said that is a
homosexual man and as they say in Latin
Naumann s Newman to name is to know once
it was known then the road to liberation
was something that had to happen and so
for me he really is the Christ figure
because he his people which we now the
LGBTQ community are it really started
the the roads of liberation started with
that moment homosexuality becoming a
word well Rupert Everett thank you so
much thank you very much everyone thank
you very much indeed
[Applause]